why do screenwriters feel like
Executives ruin their screenplays or
ideas
well
that's a good question however
I am doing listening to
um that new book that just came out
about HBO and it's an interesting thing
because a lot of the testimonies
from the writers are very positive about
how they're being supported so I do
think that you know anytime you get a
a note
it's hard you have to internalize you
have to assimilate that into your psyche
in some way and
and notes are not you know everybody
wants their thing to be great right out
of the box and it almost never is it
always takes work
so I think no matter if you're getting
it from your writer's group or you're
getting it from an executive you you're
gonna you're gonna push back on it
because you obviously turned in the
thing that you thought was ready
and then to get the no no it's not ready
there's something that needs to be done
that's like it's a little you know it's
a little hard to to stomach
but I do think there's a a whole
line of rhetoric out there about
um bad Executives and and a lot of the
bad executives are demanding they demand
your notes to be taken their notes be
taken I think the better Executives try
to again help you find
your path your own path that's why I
think you know if you're if you're
even even if you're not an executive and
you're giving notes giving a note in a
form of a question will really help ease
the pain and also you should also you
know be cognizant of the fact that maybe
somebody doesn't want to take the note
if they've taken the spirit of the note
as opposed to the exact note
and you get the point across
then
you know it should be all good but I do
think that there's there's been a
history of people who
who give
notes that seem to unravel things as
opposed to helping them and and if they
don't have a fix for it that's even
worse you know even if you say hey this
is the bad version then at least it's a
little something so there's a little bit
of light at the end of the tunnel
but I don't think anybody willingly goes
out of their way to give terrible notes
there are there may be people who are
just not equipped
they don't know enough they haven't
heard enough pitches or they haven't
been on the pitching side know how hard
it is
so there are those people who probably
shouldn't be giving notes but
hopefully if you're in a network and
you're
and your um
you're you're skilled enough to be
sitting in that room
you should be giving
fairly good notes
what's the spirit of the note mean sorry
give me the note of the under the note
yeah what is spirit you said the spirit
of the note oh the spirit of the note
sure so you know let's just say you uh
you have read my script and you give me
a very very particular
note about a particular line
well it might not be the line might not
be the problem
but what you're tapping into is there's
something not working about that scene
or that moment maybe I haven't earned
that moment yet and your note may not be
the right
identifier of that problem but if I take
a step back and go well wait maybe what
is she trying to tell me
maybe I can fix it a different way maybe
it needs to be a different scene maybe
everything's out of place remember how I
said in the beginning I took a script I
completely unraveled it and then I put
it back together again
and it worked so much better
well the note was just go deeper
he didn't give me a do it this way or
this particular way but he could have
and if he'd done that
and really the note was just go deeper
than I would have had to have looked
under that I would have had to look
under well this why is this not working
for him and take the spirit of the note
which was deeper
earn those moments
give me more character follow the
emotion
and so sometimes people don't know how
to say that and they give a very
specific here's a line problem or I
don't love this scene or it's I'm
getting bored or whatever but they don't
understand that they're not getting
bored
because the story is boring they're
getting bored because they're not
emotionally driven by the story you have
to understand what's well let me let me
figure out what they're really trying to
say why this really isn't working for
them
so the spirit is just telling you
there's just something off or go you
know they're not giving you look over
here yeah I see okay that makes sense
how many emails does an executive get
every day I I averaged about 200 of
emails a day when I was at
at HBO I'm going to say
easily 200.
and some of that is incoming stuff
agents managers some of that is catching
up with other Executives that I know
some of that was
internal
hey we've got a meeting
you know or hear notes on a script or
whatever so it's a tonnage of things
that come at you constantly that you
have to prioritize
and get to the things that are that
matter you might have a meeting coming
up you need to address you might have
just done something you need to do an
action item
so you just never know and every day is
different every day is just slightly
different where there's a new fire to be
put out
why do screenwriters think executives
are the enemy
well I think just it goes back to your
notes question which is
you know this the the executive is the
person who delivers the the notes number
one they deliver the passes number two
they're the people who say no and I
think a lot of Executives have gotten
the wrap for being risk averse and not
Taking Chances and
um sometimes that's true and sometimes
it's it's a factor that's way out of our
control so
you know but we're always the ones who
deliver that news
so it's uh it's a lot of different
things and I think the the whole process
of
of Hollywood is so random and arbitrary
and I was just thinking about how you
know we just saw Coda win best picture
and in the speech
um the director talked about how hard it
was
to get the film made
and you just go in the normal world you
can't do that movie as a big Studio
Movie they don't do those anymore you
have to go to the Indie route so imagine
all the things she had to do in order to
make that thing go or she and the
producers and
the writer and
all of those things where people were
constantly saying no
and all the people who said no right now
are kicking themselves because it was a
yes movie
and it desperately needed to be made and
it touched so many people and it changed
so many things
and yet all those people said no it only
took one person to say yes
thankfully it's out there in the world
but again think about how many other
places and other movies that that don't
get made because someone doesn't think
that it's right for them or the right
time or they don't have the budget
whatever it is whatever the reasons that
they're not going to push the button
and how many things have to really be
squeaked by there's a whole thing about
the Godfather have you seen there's like
a whole thing about the Godfather out
now about how the Godfather was made
there's like a lot of threads on Twitter
but then there's this movie that's
coming out about it and you think about
all of the ways that that could have
gone South
and it probably couldn't have it
wouldn't have made it and yet it's like
the most celebrated movie of of all time
and you go if it's just by the it's just
by some sort of magic that
it it became something
and I think they even said it at one
point that the book hadn't even been
finished at the time that they they were
starting this movie thing so it's just
it's kind of crazy
you think about if you go on that thing
there's like a Netflix show about you
know
I don't know the history of how things
got made and I think they do they do
Dirty Dancing they do
um die hard and they all have the same
story which is there is no way in the
world this movie should have gotten made
it should have it should have crashed
and burned a million different times and
those are the things that make it so
somebody had to Champion it somebody had
to say yes
um but a lot of people said no
so I think Executives in general
like it's just a miracle of
modern science that anything actually
gets gets made and turns out good
because there's just a thousand ways
that it could
you know end up uh
Heaven's Gate I guess right